so this is an example from the Khan
Academy exercise graphing solutions to
two variable linear equations and they
tell us to complete the table so each
row represents a solution of the
following equation and they give us the
equation and then they want us to figure
out what does y equal when X is equal to
negative five and what is X equal and Y
is equal to eight and to figure this out
I've actually copy and pasted this part
of the problem onto my scratch pad so
let me get let me get that out and so
this is the exact same problem there's a
couple of ways that we could try to
tackle it one way is you could try to
simplify this more get all your X's on
one side and all your Y's on the other
side or we could just literally
substitute when x equals negative 5 what
happened what must y equal actually let
me do it the second way first so if we
take this equation and we substitute X
with negative 5 what do we get we get
negative 3 times well we're going to say
X is negative 5 times negative 5 plus 7y
is equal to 5 times X is once again it's
going to be negative 5 X is negative 5 5
times negative 5 plus 2y see negative 3
times negative 5 is positive 15 plus 7y
is equal to negative 25 plus 2y and now
to solve for y let's see i could
subtract 2y from both sides so that i
get rid of the 2i here on the right so
let me subtract 2y subtract 2y from both
sides and then if I want all my
constants on the right hand side I can
subtract 15 from both sides so let me
subtract 15 from both sides and I am
going to be left with 15 minus 15 that's
0 that's the whole point of subtracting
15 from both sides so I get rid of this
15 here 7y minus 2i 7 of something minus
2 of that of that same something is
going to be 5 of that something it's
going to be equal to 5y is equal to
negative 25 minus 15 well that's going
to be negative 40 and then 2i minus 2i
that's just going to be 0 that was the
whole point of subtracting 2y from both
sides so you have 5 times y is equal to
negative
or tea or if we divide both sides by
five we divide both sides by five we
would get Y is equal to negative eight
so when X is equal to negative five y is
equal to negative eight y is equal to
negative eight and actually we can fill
that in so this Y is going to be equal
to negative eight and now we've got to
figure this out what does X equal when y
is positive eight well we can go back to
our scratch pad here and now let's take
the same equation but let's make y equal
to positive eight so you have negative
3x plus seven
now Y is going to be eight Y is eight
seven times eight is equal to five times
X plus two x once again Y is eight two
times eight so we get negative three X
plus 56 that's fifty six is equal to
five x plus sixteen now if we want to
get all of our constants on one side and
of all of our X terms on the other side
well that's what what could we do let's
see we could add 3x to both sides that
would put that would get rid of all of
the X's on this side and put them all on
this side so we're going to add 3x to
both sides and let's see if we want to
get all the constants on the left-hand
side we want to get rid of the 16 so we
could subtract 16 from the right-hand
side if we do it from the right we're
going to have to do it from the left as
well and we're going to be left with
these cancel out 56 minus 16 is positive
40 and then let's see 16 minus 16 is 0 5
X plus 3x is equal to 8x we get 8x is
equal to 40 we could divide both sides
by 8 and we get 5 is equal to X so this
right over here is going to be equal to
5 so let's go back let's go back now so
when y is positive 8 X is positive 5 now
they asked us use your two solutions to
graph the equation
so let's see if we can do a whoops let
me let me use my mouse now so to graph
the equation so what x is negative five
y is negative eight so the point
negative five comma negative eight so
that's right over there so let me move
my browser up so you can see that
negative five when X is negative five y
is negative eight and when X is positive
five we see that up here when X is
positive five y is positive eight when X
is positive five y is positive eight and
we're done we could check our answer if
we like we got it right now I said there
was two ways to tackle it I kind of just
did it I guess you could say the naive
way I just substituted negative five
directly into this and solve for y and
then I substituted y equals positive
eight directly into this and then solved
for X another way that I could have done
it that actually probably would have
been weird for sure would have been the
easier way to do it is ahead of time to
try to simplify this expression so what
I could have done right from the get-go
said hey let's put all my X's on one
side and all my Y's on the other side so
this is negative three X plus seven Y is
equal to five x plus two Y and let's say
I want to get all my Y's on the left and
all my X's on the right so I don't want
this negative three X on the left so I'd
want to add 3x adding 3x would cancel
this out but I can't just do it on the
left hand side I have to do it on the
right hand side as well
and then if I want to get rid of this
two Y on the right I could subtract 2y
from the right but of course I'd also
want to do it from the left and then
what am I left with
so negative 3x plus 3x is 0 7y minus 2y
is 5y and then i have 5x plus 3x is 8 x
2i minus 2y is 0 and then if i wanted to
i could solve for y i could divide both
sides by 5 and get y is equal to 8/5 X
so this right over here is represents
the same exact equation is this over
here it's just written in a different
way all of the XY pairs that satisfy
this would satisfy this and vice versa
and this is much easier because if X is
now negative 5 if
is negative 5y would be eight fifths
times negative five well that's going to
be negative eight and when y is equal to
eight well you actually could even do
this up here you could say five times 8
is equal to 8x and then you can see well
five times eight is the same thing as 8
times 5 so X would be equal to five so I
think this would actually been a simpler
way to do it you see it I was able to do
the entire problem this little white
space here instead of having to do all
this slightly slightly hairier algebra